foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
Boris Johnson formally quits as an MP
with a stinging rebuke to his successor
who he accuses of talking rubbish over
his resignation honors list
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right and if people
don't like that then tough
the man accused of shooting an 11 year
old British girl in France as she played
on a garden swing is investigated for
murder
I'm at the Southern District Courthouse
in Miami Florida which will tomorrow be
the scene of the latest chapter in the
tumultuous career of Donald Trump
he's arrived in Florida this evening for
the start of a legal process which could
end up with him behind bars but his
supporters are Keeping the Faith
you don't understand what it means to
shed blood for your freedom like we did
here when we broke ourselves free from a
tyrant called King George so when you
learn a little bit about our history
then I'll have a conversation
also tonight the controversial comeback
King who was a template for Trump former
Italian Prime Minister Silvio Berlusconi
dies at the age of 86.
and there was rain on their parade for
Manchester City fans celebrate their
sights trebles success
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
thank you
a very good evening Boris Johnson
formally resigned as an MP today with
the report that prompted his departure
still unpublished but before leaving
Westminster he engaged in an
extraordinary public rail with Rishi
sunak over his resignation honors the
Prime Minister accused his predecessor
of trying to bend the rules to get his
associates into the House of Lords Mr
Johnson retaliated saying he was talking
rubbish and tonight he's once again
channeled his inner Arnold
Schwarzenegger writing in a newspaper
article that he'll be back our political
editor Beth Rigby reports
these once close political Partners who
toasted each other's successes perfect
now the relationship anything but
Perfect Two former allies at War
Rishi sunak at a technology event in
London but the focus on his predecessor
around a much awaited parliamentary
report into whether Boris Johnson misled
MPS over partygate and why his allies
didn't get the peerages Mr Johnson
requested Boris Johnson asked me to do
something that I wasn't prepared to do
because I didn't think it was right that
was to you know either overrule the
holak committee automate promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
the PM locking horns with his former
boss over whether he interfered with Mr
Johnson's honors list as he sought to
put distance between the old and new
Tory regimes when I got this job I said
I was going to do things differently
because I wanted to change politics and
that's what I'm doing and I'm also Keen
to make sure that we change how our
country works but getting on with the
job hard when the party's at War within
hours Boris Johnson responding to say
Rishi sunak is talking rubbish to honor
these peerages it was not necessary to
overrule holak that's the commission
which approves peerage appointments but
simply to ask them to renew their
vetting which was a mere formality
Boris Johnson's raging about who of his
allies did or didn't get a place in the
House of Lords but in reality this is a
sideshow the bigger political earthquake
is his announcement that he's quitting
parliament in order to avoid being
potentially suspended by MPS for his
conduct over party gate it's a decision
that has rocked Westminster and now
threatens to plunge the conservatives
into another very public civil war The
Establishment has uh has seen Boris out
the door I think you know if people look
at the facts then they will they will
they either will or won't agree with me
that parliamentary privileges committee
report investigating Mr Johnson over
partygate due in the coming days and as
Mr Johnson seeks to undermine that
inquiry others stressing their decision
must be respected we have to be really
strong about calling out people who are
attacking institutions people who are
attacking the house for carrying out its
uh its work people who are attacking the
media we have to stand up for these
things because the price of not doing so
is is going to be very great indeed
another political earthquake expected
this week when the committee published
their findings over Boris Johnson's
conduct drama and distraction that an
already struggling Rishi sunak really
doesn't need Beth Rigby Sky News in
Westminster
an 11 year old girl from a British
family who was shot dead in the garden
of her home in France has been named as
celen Thornton
the child was killed while playing
outside her home in Center Beau a
village near the city of compare in
Brittany on Saturday evening Sky's Betty
Cottrell reports
it was here on Saturday night that a
family Barbecue quickly became a tragedy
eleven-year-old Celine Thornton her
younger sister and their parents were
relaxing in their Garden when a gunman
started firing at them
local authorities believe that the
shooter was their elderly neighbor and
that there was a long-running dispute
the family's dad was doing Garden work
on the hedges separating the two
properties this exacerbated the
situation later the suspect took a
loaded 22 millimeter rifle three to four
shots were fired hitting the three
victims
celane was killed and both her parents
were injured her father Adrian is in a
critical condition with life-threatening
wounds their youngest daughter
eight-year-old Celeste managed to escape
the gunfire and raise the alarm a local
resident told us they saw Celeste
running to a neighbor's house she was
rushing to tell them her sister was dead
it's hard to imagine what the young girl
has seen and been through it's believed
this had been their home for four or
five years
located in Brittany in the west of
France the Thornton's home is in San
elbow a tiny rural Hamlet near the city
of camper the small community has been
left devastated
[Music]
matild was in the same class as Solen
she told us how she heard the news
[Music]
it was Sunday I've been surfing and I
was in the car and my mum told me yes
it's terrible
the suspect is a Dutch national he shut
himself in his house with his wife after
the shooting military negotiators
persuaded him to give himself up so he
could be arrested
this is a close-knit community where
people know their neighbors they can't
believe one of them would kill a child
because of what appears to be a grudge
over a garden lekki Cottrell Sky News
San elbow in Brittany
welcome to Miami Florida where Donald
Trump arrived earlier this evening ahead
of an appearance at the court behind me
tomorrow the former president faces 37
felony counts relating to retaining
classified information
obstructing justice and making full
statements will the indictment marks the
first time in U.S history that a former
president faces criminal charges by the
federal government that he once oversaw
if convicted he faces the possibility of
prison with the charge of obstruction of
justice carrying the highest penalty of
up to 20 years a U.S correspondent Mark
Stone has been on the former president's
Trail ahead of another day in court
tomorrow
on home turf for what could be the most
consequential prosecution in U.S history
America's 45th president but the first
to face something like this
what a slow drive for the president as
he approaches his golf club but I have
to say there are more media here than
there are supporters he will surely be
hoping that the base swells a bit more
than this
[Music]
[Applause]
the support that was here conservative
from across the Spectrum was angry
determined and representing many more
across the country he's you know being
pecked on really all the other
presidents have done the same thing he's
doing I think the allegations against
Joe Biden and his family are
significantly more serious than the ones
against Donald Trump it breaks my heart
to think that we are on a way to
becoming a Banana Republic here outside
the Miami Courthouse the stage is being
set to record this spectacle the most
high profile person ever to face
criminal charges under the Espionage Act
when the indictment was unsealed Donald
Trump was on his golf course spotted by
Sky News through the weekend we've
followed him to rallies across the
country
in Columbus Georgia the setting was an
old factory which once made guns for the
Civil War
is in places like this not the courtroom
where he is presenting his defense to
crowds of riled supporters
and with his political allies too on
Niche Network's broadcasting to just one
side this is Carrie Lake one time
Arizona governor hopeful she lost claims
she was robbed and is now Trump's
cheerleader I think think people are
going to Rally around president Trump we
know that our elections are corrupt here
they've been corrupt for a long time
2020. we saw what happened when we
ignored a corrupt election and allowed
someone like Joe Biden to get into the
White House and Lead our country into
destruction and I just make you can you
can look down the camera and say that
but you know that's not true you know
that the election was not still no I
wouldn't expect you coming from
Australia to know one damn you're from
the UK country oh you're from the UK I
was told you're from Australia Carrie
Lake could conceivably be Donald Trump's
running mate for vice president expect
you to understand what's happening in
our country because I can see you've
come at this from a left agenda which is
very typical of the fake news
the seriousness of the charges are not
the focus here because they believe this
is a hit job by Biden to remove his
political rival they point to Joe
Biden's own Scandal and the documents
found at his home his son Hunter and
that laptop both under investigation and
to the Hillary Clinton scandal the
difference though between those and
Trump is quantity and the allegations
that Trump intended to take the
documents and try to hide them
his date in court is tomorrow afternoon
Mark Stone Sky News in Miami
well our International correspondent
John Sparks is at Donald Trump's
National de Royal Resort in Miami where
the former president is currently
staying and uh you know aside from the
protest that might be planned John it
genuinely will be quite a moment when a
former U.S president voluntarily
surrenders himself to the authorities
for a federal case accusing him of
risking National Security
you're right Anna it is an absolutely
huge moment I can tell you that he
arrived here at the Doral Country Club
which he also happens to own a couple of
hours ago as part of a 10-car cavalcade
day they didn't rush in they slowly went
through the gates and I understand that
he was met by his son Eric and that he
looks somber he looks somber at the time
big moment for him big moment for the
City of Miami as well they've canceled
police leave they will be wary of the
escalating rhetoric surrounding this
indictment a serious moment for them
when you consider that there may be
hundreds or even thousands of pro-trump
supporters and opponents in the center
of the city as well so a big moment for
them uh as well Trump has got his legal
homework to do he needs a legal strategy
he may also need a another lawyer as
well part of the process tomorrow may be
his arraignment where he gets to enter a
plea guilty or not guilty we expect of
course that he will plead not guilty to
all 37 counts he needs a local lawyer to
get him through that part of the process
or he'll have to come back and do it
again I don't suppose he wants that and
interestingly tonight real opposition
being expressed in the Republican party
from Nikki Haley one of his competitors
for the nomination the Republican
nomination is in the presidency and the
attorney general who served under Trump
during his presidency he said even if
half of the allegations and the
indictment are true that Donald Trump is
toast
yes John are the Sans shifting thank you
very much indeed for that well the scene
here in downtown Miami will certainly
look very different when Donald Trump
arrived for his hearing tomorrow
afternoon Trump supporters are expected
to be bussed into the city from other
parts of Florida leading to concerns
over potential unrest the former
president is planning to return then to
New Jersey straight after his court
appearance to hold a press conference as
well as a fundraising event a reminder
that despite the dozens of indictments
he is facing Donald Trump is still
planning to run for re-election in 2024
worth remembering too that on Wednesday
he will celebrate his 77th birthday we
will of course have full coverage of
tomorrow's events live on Sky News for
now though it's back to Sally Lockwood
for the rest of the day's news Sally
Anna thank you well today the death was
announced of a man who was in many ways
the prototype for Donald Trump's
political career former Italian Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi started like
Trump as a business tycoon but ended up
as the country's longest-serving
post-war leader with enduring popularity
despite a series of scandals he died
today aged 86 after a long illness
while our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons has been looking back at
berlusconi's life and his report
contains some flash photography
he was impossible to ignore Silvio
Berlusconi was a giant figure in Italian
life for decades on end in politics
business Sport and on the global stage
he played the game into his 80s part of
the Coalition that won Italy's last
general election and pushed Georgia
Maloney into power
he was a man who was never afraid to
defend his beliefs and it was exactly
that courage and determination that made
him one of the most influential men in
the history of Italy that allowed him to
make real turning points in the world of
politics communication in the world of
business with him Italy learned that it
should never have limits imposed Italy
learned that it should never give up
his death was not a surprise but it
still felt like a shock to many
today I'm in pain he's like a family
member who's given me something all my
life but today I cannot think about
tomorrow
from the center right Berlusconi LED
four separate governments spending more
time as prime minister than any other
post-war Italian politician we find
Silvio Berlusconi guilty but it was
never straightforward he was cited in
dozens of criminal investigations mostly
around claims of fraud
trouble followed him Berlusconi was
convicted of paying a Moroccan dance of
a sex when she was just 17 years old at
one of his lavish bunga bunga parties
but he won an appeal and laughed off the
Scandal bunga bunga even became a
catchphrase then came a conviction for
tax fraud that he couldn't beat
Berlusconi was at his lowest Deb and
protested furiously on one of his own TV
stations in exchange for the commitment
I have made over almost 20 years in
favor of my country and coming almost at
the end of my public life I received as
a reward accusations and a verdict that
is founded on absolutely enough it takes
away my personal freedom and my
political rights but he was blessed with
an infectious smile Rolling Stone
magazine once named him their rock star
of the year
[Music]
lifted and gleaming his smile he never
retired from public life campaigning and
Charming to the end
Berlusconi was a showman a politician
who lived for the spotlight
Alex Rossi Sky News Milan
Alex Rossi reporting there the Scottish
national party says it's not going to
suspend its former leader Nicholas
sturgeon after her arrest in connection
with an investigation into the party's
finances Ms sturgeon has been released
without charge pending further
investigations our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis reports
emerging in Inverness steeped in another
crisis fresh political and personal pain
for a first Minister after his ally
friend and predecessor Nicholas
sturgeon's arrest I won't be suspending
Nicholas and I'll be treating her
exactly in the same way as I treated for
example colombiti both released without
charge and therefore there's no reason
for me to suspend them I have great
confidence in the future of my party in
an explosive development Nicholas
sturgeon faced seven hours of detention
by police examining the snp's finances
and funding released without charge
pending further inquiries she insisted
she was innocent of wrongdoing but some
within the party believe she should step
aside
I should consider whether it might be
appropriate considering what has been
going on over the last few weeks for her
to resign her party membership uh
voluntarily just temporarily
[Applause]
this has been the toughest time the SMP
has suffered these the images of the
raid on Nicholas sturgeon's home in
April the same day her husband Peter
model was detained and released without
charge
their political opponents attempting to
capitalize and canvas support I'm more
interested in what it means for The
Wider country and what it means for how
they operate in government this is a
political party that is famed now for a
culture of secrecy and cover-up in
government and that has had devastating
consequences it's now an incompetent and
dysfunctional SNP government and that's
why we need fundamental change
it's quite frankly the key set Nicholas
sturgeon with a suspended Nicholas
sturgeon because when she was leader of
the SMP and SMP politicians were
arrested and questioned by the police
she either removed the party Whip or she
suspended them there are some within the
SMP who fear this police probe
regardless of the outcome risks causing
major electoral damage and they now want
some distance with their former leader
and as police continue to examine what
Nicholas sturgeon said under caution in
that interview will she now be feeling
that she is becoming a distraction to
the party that she's fought for her
entire political career
as the police continue their inquiries
the political heat is Extreme once again
where the stakes could not be higher
Conor Gillis Sky News Glasgow
[Applause]
the cost of living crisis has been felt
across the country but a Sky News
investigation has found it even extends
to some military personnel and their
families who are now relying on food
banks our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes has this exclusive report
defending Europe from Attack
delivering support during covid and on
display for the king the UK's Armed
Forces play a crucial role in National
life yet Sky News can reveal that high
inflation and Rising costs have tipped
some into crisis an internal analysis by
military chaplains said the cost of
living had hit morale across the Royal
Air Force last year an anonymous quote
in the report read the food bank is
popular a footnote then added Food Bank
use is reported across a majority of
units but nowhere is yet reporting
widespread use single figures per unit
of families utilizing food banks is a
working estimate
a food bank has been set up here at Raf
coningsby in Lincolnshire originally it
was intended to collect donations from
aviators to give to civilians in the
area but A source told me RAF Personnel
are using it as well
a second report written last year by
officials here said the cost of living
crisis is severely affecting Personnel
at coningsby and this will ultimately be
reflected at all other defense
establishments the paper said some
people were having to decide whether to
buy food or fuel
what would really help service Personnel
here at Raf coningsby and across the UK
is a decent pay rise the military unlike
most public sector workers aren't
allowed to go on strike for better
conditions instead they're the ones that
are called upon to fill in for others
that do take industrial action
the armed forces are waiting for this
year's pay rise an announcement that has
been delayed when it comes it will be
welcomed but it almost certainly won't
be enough
a spokesperson for the RAF said the food
bank at Raf coningsby was not set up by
the RAF for its personnel and the RAF
offers a range of support such as
welfare officers who can offer Financial
advice and access to fuel grants and
hardship funds provided by the RAF and
supporting Charities and associations
senior Minister said no one in the RAF
army or navy should have to use food
banks I know that defense ministers will
be concerned about your reports will
want to investigate and will want to do
everything possible to make sure that
our men and women in uniform are
properly looked after
people don't join the military to get
rich but they do leave if they're not
paid enough
Deborah Haynes Sky News
two children found dead in Stoke on
Trent yesterday have been named by
police as Elizabeth and Ethan John
the seven and eleven-year-old were both
found unresponsive with significant
injuries inside a home on Flax Street a
49 year old woman has been arrested on
suspicion of murder and remains in
custody
a woman has been jailed for more than
two years by a court in Stoke-on-Trent
after illegally obtaining drugs to carry
out an abortion the 44 year old lied
about how far Advanced her pregnancy was
to obtain the pills during lockdown in
2020 her child was still born at between
32 and 34 weeks gestation
now the covert inquiry hasn't been far
from the headlines in recent weeks with
an ongoing row between the government
and the inquiries chair over disclosure
of materials that is likely to end up in
court but tomorrow the inquiry will
begin its first hearings where the
substance of the government's response
to the pandemic will take Center Stage
guys Ashish Joshi reports
it was a virus that destroyed lives and
livelihoods its Legacy will be felt for
years to come
Ranjit chandrapala was a London bus
driver one of 27 to die from covid-19 in
the first three months of the pandemic
his daughter leshi expects answers
he contracted covid in April so
had you know certain measures been in
place you know at his Depot and on his
buses maybe he would still be alive he
was definitely left exposed he had no
PPE to speak of they gave him
um gloves and that was it and hand
sanitizer
from this evening I must give the
British people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home decisions made
during the pandemic are about to come
under intense scrutiny for the first
time in our history the government is
going to step in and help to pay
people's wages we've tried to throw a
protective ring around our Care Homes
it's a process that will take years and
cost at least tens of millions of pounds
this inquiry is going to go much deeper
than simply weighing up one policy
Choice against another it's going to
look at the government's conduct during
the pandemic and ask if that matched
what the country would reasonably expect
from its leaders in a time of crisis
soon the focus will be on the
government's decision making including
policies such as eat out to help out
pushed by the then chancellorishi sunak
which has been criticized by some
government advisors
so taking your foot off the break is one
thing but putting your foot on the
accelerator of the epidemics was in my
view a very different thing and um
couldn't see any any reason for doing it
that you know I just think thought that
at the time that it would
Kickstart the next wave the inquiries
opening has been overshadowed by Boris
Johnson's resignation from Parliament
following an investigation into alleged
lockdown breaches and the controversy
over government WhatsApp messages
but for bereaved families nothing must
be allowed to distract the inquiry as it
begins its search for the truth oh she's
Josh he's Sky News
now despite a delay following warnings
of potential lightning strikes nothing
could stop Manchester City supporters
from celebrating their team's treble
success this evening
tens of thousands of jubilant Blues fans
lined the streets for the start of the
two-hour celebrations despite fears of a
major thunderstorm that threatened to
hit the city center at the same time and
ended up delaying the start of the
parade by half an hour
when it did finally get underway the
open top bus with the Victorious squad
team from Istanbul the Champions League
trophy and the Premier League trophy
alongside it made its way slowly through
the packed streets several times the
Champions League trophy was lifted to
the Delight of fans as the players
continue to party on the top deck
and undaunted by the weather it all
culminated with a stage appearance led
by Holland the players and their manager
were hailed by their fans as only the
second english team in history to
achieve the treble last time it was
their Rivals United this time the
bragging rights belonged to city and
their captain
say thank you very much Francis for all
the support during the whole season it's
been incredible and we got to be trophy
and finally the fans got to see all
three of those Trophies the Champions
League premier league and FA Cup being
lifted once again all together a
remarkable end to a remarkable season
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll be taking a first look at
tomorrow's papers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
Metro about the Russians in the
conservative party their headline all
out War
tonight we're joined by pivot queer
political editor at the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor at the sun
do join us next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is Sky News in just a moment the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive but first
our top stories Boris Johnson has
accused the prime minister of talking
rubbish after Rishi sunak said Mr
Johnson had asked him to overrule the
committee that vets nominees for honors
police are investigating the killing of
an 11 year old British girl in Northwest
France who was shot dead playing in her
family's Garden
and Donald Trump has flown into Miami
where he'll face criminal charges in
court tomorrow
[Music]
there you're watching the Press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive and it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
Pippa career political editor at the
guardian and Harry Cole political editor
at the sun they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight we'll be
speaking to them in just a sec but let's
have a look first at what's on some of
those front pages
all out War that's how the Metro
describes what it calls the vicious
verbal blows being traded between Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson over the former
prime minister's resignation honors list
the time says that the commons
privileges committee has concluded that
Mr Johnson did mislead Parliament when
he told MPS he'd been advised that he
did not break covid-19 rules
in the midst of all this the mirror
speaks up for the families of people who
died from covid and says they deserve
better
and although Boris Johnson has now
resigned as an MP he tells the express
Express in an exclusive interview
believe me I shall return to Frontline
politics
the males says labor stands accused of
abandoning the law-abiding majority by
failing to back curbs on disruptive
eco-protest groups such as just stop oil
the guardian pippa's paper leads with
news of a woman who was jailed for
procuring drugs for an abortion after
the legal time limit had passed
the eye reports what it calls a Russian
intelligence agent is now living in the
UK with his family having been housed
under the government scheme to help
homeless Ukrainian families
the financial times so as a committee of
MPS is to question top officials at the
financial conduct authority over sexual
misconduct allegations made against
hedge fund manager Crispin Odie
Harry's paper the sun focuses on the
aftermath of Manchester City's treble
winning celebrations showing Kyle Walker
helping a somewhat worse for wear Jack
grealish and the headline having trouble
Jack
and the star has news of what it says
was a UFO crash in the 1930s that was
hushed up by the then Pope according to
a former U.S Air Force official
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by Pippa queer
and Harry Cole let's get started shall
we great to have you both with us thanks
so much for joining us
um kicking off with the front page of
the Daily Express that exclusive uh
interview that Boris Johnson has given
to the express where he says believe me
I shall return to Frontline politics I
saw you give a little laugh at that
Harry what's your response tell us more
about this
I'm not sure if it's um with all due
respect to our friends at the express
I'm not sure if it's an interview and
more of a text message um it seems to be
a very short single quote from Boris
Johnson
um something we've heard from him before
when he resigned of course as pm he said
hasta la vista baby I'll be back and um
obviously he is a thousand word
statement uh late on Friday night he
right at the end there uh ducked in
there a little a little reference to uh
I'm leaving Parliament for now
um look Boris Johnson I think almost
likes the idea of the comeback more than
it's ever going to happen it's a very
odd way of staging a sort of coup
against Rishi suneck as some people have
alleged he's doing uh by exiting the
stage so
um it's all sort of uh fighting talk I
think and today we've seen
astonishing barbs traded in public
between a prime minister and their
predecessor or an ex-priminister and
their successor Richard sunac has kept
his powder dry over the weekend he was
away in Washington until Friday we all
flew back from from DC and the sort of
Boris news blew up late on Friday night
the Prime Minister didn't respond to any
of the any of the barbs from Johnson
over the weekend but my gosh did he save
up his um his punch and um seen as a bit
of a technocrat quite a mild-mannered
polite man but you could tell he was
very angry and I can't remember a time
that a prime minister has gone so hard
after their predecessor only even the
days of of Gordon and Tony and and
Thatcher and Heath these these sort of
things take years to Bubble over what
we've got is the two big piece of the
conservative party trading public blows
12 months away from an election and you
just think what does the public make of
this it is an astonishing turn of events
yeah pip I can I can see you nodding
there and certainly it's extraordinary
isn't it we as Harry says we've seen
these big political feuds before but
it's so rare to see this public
mudslinging and inside the times they go
into more detail about uh some of you
know what Boris Johnson supposedly
pressed Rishi sunakon
yeah the time is has this well we know I
mean we knew that Boris Johnson wanted
to give his father Stanley Johnson a
Knighthood and there was a uh a story
several weeks ago
um about it being about being blocked
obviously there's a distinction between
the peerages that Boris Johnson
um put on his list he wanted 16 of those
and then and and the uh the committee
that
um that goes through all these things
for House of Lords blocked half of them
and then on the other hand this was all
the other honors so the the knighthoods
and the cbes and then bees and so on
which went through the cabinet office
for vetting and the time suggestion is
that um in the in the recent discussion
there was last week you know last week
when Richardson Boris Johnson sat down
and tried to smash out some sort of
compromise on this
um that um Boris Johnson had actually
pressed so like again for his father to
be awarded awarded a Knighthood exciting
the example of previous Prime Ministers
that have given family members
um gongs Theresa May
um obviously her husband Philip received
one and other other Ministry of prime
ministerial spices have in the past not
as far as I know Prime ministerial
parent although Stanley Johnson was of
course an MEP for some time and an
environmentalist but is nevertheless a
quite controversial figure
um not least in his attitude and some of
his behavior towards women
um so this is really just one example of
where the route between them erupted
and Boris Johnson is obviously feeling
very hard done by that
um Rishi sinak did not intervene on his
behalf And Delay the system the vetting
system so that the MPS that he wanted to
make peerages uh to meet peers uh could
could stay in in their seats for now but
still have a sort of a smooth transition
if you like to be to the House of Lords
ahead of the election but as Harry's
already said really bad blood between
the two men this evening and um and you
know that sort of conservative Blue on
Blue infighting the one thing part one
thing the public hates more than
anything is uh divided parties fighting
amongst themselves uh and because it
looks like they're they're just focused
on on you know their own Futures and
their own selves and not on all the many
issues facing the country like the cost
of living crisis the NHS
yeah and and Harry's certainly the front
page of the Metro uh calls it all out
War what do you make of this you know
public falling out that we that we're
now seeing play out do you think that
Boris Johnson is going to pose more
problems for Russia sunac outside of
parliament or inside
well he's resigned formerly as an MP
today he is no longer an MP officially
um and he's you know he's upended
Downing streets weak uh quite
spectacularly once uh this week and I
wonder whether he'll do it do it again
look he's it he's clearly aggrieved he
feels that he was misled perhaps not
directly perhaps he wasn't told a lie to
his face but misled by what she said
that didn't tell him though they clearly
Met 10 days ago in Parliament they had
secret peace talks as as the Times
report and the Sunday Times reported
earlier on Sunday
um you know they discussed periods they
discussed Stanley Johnson's Knighthood
but two people left that meeting with
two very different interpretations of
what was promised Richie sunac is
adamant that he said I won't do a deal I
won't do a promise I won't I won't make
any any any any sort of bending of the
rules was what he came out publicly
today but Johnson was left with the
impression that his list was going to go
through without with those MPS names on
it now is there a conspiracy here or is
it up is it probably a bit of both
I just expect so what is clear is
Downing Street did not want three
by-elections this week
um announced it will come probably at
the end of July that is what they were
seeking to avoid however that's what
they've now got now Johnson is Raging he
feels like he's being betrayed Nadine
Doris is equally publicly vocalizing the
Betrayal narrative she's gone on talk TV
tonight straight for quote the Posh boys
who that she thinks has stitched her up
there's a girl from Liverpool who was
promised a peerage has had that taken
away because she was outspoken and had a
big mouth this is not gonna these people
don't have anything to lose really
they're not trying to hold their seats
they have a very high profile media sort
of platforms now and I can't see them
going quietly into the night so I think
that's why we saw sunac today come out
and try and punch Boris on the nose
quite hard to just give a little message
which is hang on mate look you know I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna take this lying
down and it seems that down and Street
are going to fight fire with fire and
just Barry from you both before we move
on a you gov poll found only a quarter
of those asked want to see Boris Johnson
return he's obviously saying in the
express tomorrow I'll be back do you see
that happening Pippa
well we're we're reporting tonight in
the guardian that uh Rishi sinach would
block his return to the Tory candidates
list uh should he try and make a
comeback this side of a general election
so in short no I don't see that
happening anytime soon but as we've all
learned with Boris Johnson over very
many years is you never say never yeah
quite Harry briefly
there's no return for Boris Johnson and
he knows that and he's vocalized that to
people many times that until the
fundamentals change until the
Parliamentary makeup changes there is no
way back and if Richard wins the next
election by hooker by crook you know
it's his party for five years if he
loses because Boris Johnson really want
to come back and be lead of the
opposition but you know 10 years time
who knows yeah quite who knows uh let's
get on to the front page of your paper
Pippa the guardian
um really interesting and really
controversial story about a woman who's
been jailed uh for taking abortion pills
after the legal cut-off limit tell us
more about this
yes so um in England Wales and Scotland
uh most abortions legally have to take
place but before 24 weeks many of them
of course take place way before that in
the very early few early uh first few
weeks of pregnancy and after 24 weeks in
some limited circumstances for example
if a woman's life is in danger as a
result of a pregnancy or if there's no
Prospect of the baby surviving there are
certain medical situations where doctors
can make a judgment that actually it's
in uh boost their best interests
um uh to another pregnancy not to
proceed and but what's happened here is
that a mother of a mother of three
received what became known as pills by
post during the pandemic and from early
stage abortions pre-10 weeks
um it was uh introduced for unwanted
pregnancies after remote consultation
because obviously women it was harder
for women to get out to see their doctor
or to or to these clinics
um and she apparently
um when she applied for these drugs she
um had claimed that she was
um she was blue 10 weeks and actually by
the time she took them she was about
seven or eight months pregnant which is
way further Way Beyond
um the cutoff period and as a result uh
she's been she pleaded guilty
um but she has been sentenced and will
spend half of her sentence about just
over a year in custody and the other
half
um on license
um and that this is despite the fact
that uh in the various expert groups so
um the Royal College of Obstetricians
and various other
um pregnancy
um the Royal College of midwives raise
all the experts groups had written a
letter signed a mitigation plea to the
judge in an attempt to uh to sort of
warn him or warn the judge that they
potentially were setting out a dangerous
precedent putting women off uh going for
support and help should they need it
later in pregnancy and of course this
woman clearly was in a very fragile
emotional state in this prison the best
place for a mother of three that's
obviously been through a very difficult
circumstances so you know this is a
story which will prompt or no doubt
strong views on either side of the
abortion debate I mean it must be said
reminded that the vast majority people
in this country support abortion I think
people get crazier the later it happens
um and cases like this will inevitably
spark debates about what the right
limits are and whether women should be
punished regardless of the reasoning
behind it for for taking action
um later on in pregnancy as this woman
did okay Peppa yep a very sad story on
many levels thank you both so much we're
just going to cut to a short break and
give you a little bit of a breather
coming up we'll have more from the
papers including this story on the front
page of tomorrow's ft their headline
Berlusconi dies at 86 leaving Big
questions for Maloney's right-wing
government we'll have more than that
coming up
[Music]
thank you we aim to be the best and most
trusted place for news
[Music]
Greg myland Sky News Manchester
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I'm in zamam Rasheed and I'm Skies north
of England correspondent telling stories
from this culturally Rich region I call
home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
if the Taliban found your family what
would happen I think they're just going
to straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was in the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically sick so I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me is peppercareer
political editor at the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor at the sun
let's kick off with you if I may Harry
an article in your paper uh tomorrow
about Sadiq Khan's office uh Banning the
reference to men and women what's going
on
you might wonder whether Sadiq Khan
would spend most of his time tackling
the Deep problems at the Met or perhaps
storing knife crime in the capital or
congestion the fact you can't really get
around the tubes overheating today but
no uh the Sun have got a hold of his um
his style guide so to speak where staff
at City Hall have been told not to say
men and women because apparently that's
uh that's offensive I'm not quite sure
to who to uh not to say EU migrants to
say uh for let's say London is from
Europe and various other things on this
list that go through that reads like a
sort of almost like a private artist
spoof of someone desperately trying to
be ultra awoke and and hip and right on
but actually just sounding a little bit
mad and and maybe a bit confusing for
many people
um Pippa the financial times
um leading with a tribute to Berlusconi
of course who who's died at the age of
86 and questions about what that could
mean for Georgia Maloney's uh coalition
yeah I mean
uh seems to be around forever doesn't he
I remember there's pictures of him and
Tony Blair meeting on the on various
trips to Tuscany uh long and
controversial career
um that re-ranged as if FT says from
billionaire media magnet to trailblazing
populist
um and he was on and off leader of Italy
for over a decade
um in total uh which was marked of
course by the criminal investigation
it's his business Affairs and indeed the
sex scandals who can forget the bunga
bunga parties
um and uh but he was always active even
towards the end of his life in Italian
politics and he played a leading role in
the crisis that actually brought down
Mario dragi's government last year and
helped to form Georgia Maloney's ruling
Coalition but because of that uh key
role that he played at that point uh
questions have been questions have been
asked about the division of power
between Maloney's right-wing Coalition
now and the future of his fort sotalia
party
um which doesn't have to your successor
so
um you know it remained an instrumental
and influential figure in Italian and
European politics
um despite his advancing years uh and
despite the fact he was no longer in
power himself uh he was very much
somebody who was sitting there pulling
the strings so a major change in Italian
politics tonight uh with the death of
Silvio Berlusconi okay Pippa Harry we'll
leave it there and we'll see you again
next hour thank you both so much let's
have a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
the weather will become increasingly
settled and less humid over the east
from the East I should say over the next
few days temperatures will drop a few
degrees but it will remain warm for most
North Sea coasts will feel fresher
Central parts of Ireland will be largely
cloudy with outbreaks of rain to start
tomorrow the UK Mainland though will be
fine with plenty of sunshine low cloud
and sea fog in the far North and the
South will burn back to coastal areas
and it'll be a mild and humid night with
temperatures in the mid to high teens
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
[Music]
foreign